Qatar eight stadiums 15 000 cameras to
pass undetected is practically
impossible however creative agency
virtue worldwide together with Danish
company brand house Sub-Zero turned the
flags of participating countries into
patterns that confuse the facial
recognition algorithm with the help of
AI how does it work a particular pattern
of shapes is drawn on the face this
makes it more difficult for cameras to
capture and determine where the eyes
nose and mouth are located this is the
key data needed to recognize you in a
crowd to find out whether or not this
makeup actually works you can test it
out with the help of Apple face ID or
see if Instagram filters can recognize
your face just don't pay any attention
to Snapchat their filters often say
anything for a face if you are able to
make yourself invisible to these
Technologies then most likely the
surveillance cameras will not be able to
identify you subscribe to Samsung we'll
keep you from getting lost in the online
jungle